- [Voiceover] Why do you like pie so much?
- Okay this is why I like pie so much:
pastry dough, filling,
hot, flakey,
crusty.
(groovy music)
- [Voiceover] We're in China,
town.
About to eat some pie,
because I'm gonna eat pies
from around the world.
Reppin' China, where I'm from,
Beijing Pie House.
The word pie is in the title,
that means that there's gonna be pie here.
(groovy music)
Pies.
I don't think this is
gonna be like an American
knife and fork pie.
Obviously.
So, we'll just see what we get.
Pie time.
hashtag...
wold of pie.
These look like
flattened giant dumpings.
Like this, seems weird.
I feel like, okay, well
don't know how to do this.
Eat it with my hands.
Here we go.
This is gonna get hot.
Hot, hot, hot pocket.
That's delicious.
It's delicious, that does not
need any soy sauce at all.
That is...
very tasty.
Pie dough should be flakey,
let me tell you if it has that.
This is not flakey.
- [Voiceover] Is it pie?
- (chuckles) I don't know if this is pie.
I don't know if this is pie.
Verdict is: delicious,
confused as to whether
or not it's still pie.
Hey I just got some spinach pie,
and I'm gonna eat it the way
everyone should eat
spinach pie in the car.
What?
- Woah!
Now,
this is a lot of spinach pie.
Here we go.
I notice that that's my
term whenever I eat food now
I go: here we go.
- [Voiceover] Do you always, uh,--
- I never--
- [Voiceover] talk with
your mouth full too?
- No.
Well this is delicious.
Let's open our minds more.
Does pie have to be...
flakey?
No, that's what we learned from China.
Does pie have to be...
circular? Spherical?
Noo.
- [Voiceover] Well
spherical would be weird
that would be like a basketball of pie.
- You're right. Wrong word--
- [Voiceover] That'd be delicious though.
- 3-D pie.
Verdict is...
it's pie.
(groovy music)
Verdict is good.
I like Greek pie.
(groovy music)
Well I don't have to
introduce what this is
because I think everyone
is familiar with quiche.
I consider this a pie because
it has the crust,
this one has zucchini
and red pepper and feta.
Google translate...
quiche means quiche.
That's a joke from
National Lampoon's European Vacation
why did I fall for that? (chuckles)
That is like, I knew that.
I knew that already that
quiche means quiche.
This is good.
Let's see if the crust is
as tasty as the filling.
Mmhmm. Buttery.
Flakey.
You know those little
noodles you get
those extra noodles you
get with Chinese takeout?
Kinda taste like that a little bit.
This is the tastiest so far.
But I think we're gonna
have to stop for today.
So I can finish this entire pie.
And then we'll
come back and do three more.
(groovy music)
As you can tell it's day two,
because I'm wearing different clothes.
We're gonna get more pie.
(groovy music)
Day two, world of pie.
This is a chicken pot pie from Australia.
Mmmm.
I know it's savory inside.
Well I know cause I ordered it but,
I can taste savoriness
waiting for me inside.
Hi, can you see what's inside?
Oo, you see chicken.
You see vegetables.
You see potatoes.
This is an entire meal...
that's in a pie form...
that's sort of like a muffin, too.
I'm having a little bit of trouble here.
Verdict is: very good.
I would love to eat this for dinner.
I think it's a good sign
when your hands look like this afterwards,
when they're filled with buttery crumbs.
- [Voiceover] And you
have a crumb on your face.
- I think that's a good sign too.
So now we're at Stella Barra,
which is in Hollywood.
And we're gonna get a pizza pie
to represent Italy.
(groovy music)
Is that roasted garlic?
- Yea, this is roasted garlic, and uh,
Calabrian chile.
- [Voiceover] How many minutes?
- Uh, right now, probably
about 10 to 12 minutes.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
I'll see you in 10 to 12 minutes, friend.
- (laughs)
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- [Voiceover] I'm so excited for pizza.
Pizza pie.
Hi pizza.
Hullo, we knew you when
you were just dough.
Mmmm.
Is this pie?
I don't care.
I honestly don't.
You know what I've noticed
about all of these pies?
Is that, they all have crust.
Maybe that's what defines a pie,
that it has to have crust;
dough...
surrounding a filling.
I'm gonna crack that code.
(groovy music)
This is downtown L.A.
We're about to go to The Pie Hole
for the American pie.
(groovy music)
I'm just checking my hair.
Hair looks good.
It's the final stop,
we're in downtown L.A.
and we're at The Pie Hole.
And, I ordered an apple pie.
I like that the apples are...
really sweet, but very tart.
It's a little crips, but not mushy
at all.
That's a nice crust.
That is a flakey, buttery crust.
This is a pie.
This is definitely a pie.
Get some of the cinnamon action
oozing out on the side.
So my verdict is that America wins,
because if there's one thing
that our country knows how to do,
it's how to inject sugar into food.
And we have won
big-time in the pie category.
It's as American as...
this pie.
(groovy music)
(whooshing)
(moves into creaking hinges)